well the problem of unemployment is a
very very serious one insofar as Egypt
is concerned we are trying to cope with
the complex problem of poverty and
unemployment I suggested as a candidate
for the presidency that we should pay
the youth unemployed youth a certain
amount of money monthly but on condition
that they would and all in the
government and private sector programs
for
for rehabilitation and that they and
they stay on that program for 10 months
but this is the duration of the
financial program that the government
would pay for them what an addition to
that we have to come up with
the projects of major proportions
to create job opportunities in a big way
and also to revive they like the Suez
Canal rehabilitation as I have suggested
at the same time the small and
medium-sized industries will have to be
properly financed and promoted so with
those three programs and the
the functioning
economy when we
start rebuilding the country elected the
president and
the new government avid stability that
would bring in again the necessary
investments and tourism
major projects like the abolition of the
Suez Canal the
promotion of small and medium-sized
industries
the
financing of certain
young be certain age bracket and trying
to
rehabilitate they
the ocean people and creating new
education you too
this would cope with unemployment in
perhaps in a quicker way